During the period when the Earth is furthest
from the sun (aphelion), the average temperature
of the entire planet is about 4°F (2.3°C)
higher than when it is closest to the sun
(perihelion).
On average, the intensity of sunlight falling
on Earth during aphelion is about 7% less
than during perihelion.
Despite this, the Earth ends up being warmer
during the period in which it is furthest
away from the sun.
So what’s going on here?
During the winter months, for the Northern
Hemisphere, the overall temperature of the
Southern Hemisphere, where it is summer, doesn’t
change as much as the other way around.
This is because a much larger portion of the
Southern Hemisphere, compared to the Northern
Hemisphere, is made up of water and water
has a significantly greater heat capacity
than land.
On a similar vein then, during the summer
for the Southern Hemisphere, the overall average
temperature of the Southern Hemisphere doesn’t
increase as much as the Northern Hemisphere
does during its summer, for this same reason.
So the “tl;dr” version is: there is a
lot more land in the Northern Hemisphere than
the Southern Hemisphere; this land heats up
much faster than water and water cools down
much slower than land.
So even though there is less intensity of
sunlight during the summer in the Northern
Hemisphere, the Earth’s average temperature
is higher at this time when it’s furthest
from the sun.
As you might have guessed then or already
known, the seasons are not caused by the distance
the Earth is from the sun, but rather are
caused completely by the fact that the Earth
is tilted on its axis 23.5°.
This is why when it’s summer in the Northern
Hemisphere, it’s winter in the Southern
Hemisphere, and vice-verse.
Without this tilt, there would be no seasons
and the weather from day to day across the
globe would be relatively uniform.
In this case, there would only be a very slight
variation in temperature as the Earth got
closer or further away from the Sun, but for
the most part, everything weather-wise would
stay the same year round.